[Music]
all right our podcast Lords of gaming
down there all these fine people in the
realm today I'm Ryan Baker I'm lead
designer on zombie army four so let's
get into tell us a little bit about this
game so this game is a third-person
incorporative shooter 80s horror movie
oh we like that we like a t-table
Ewing's violent okay he's just setting
up this time around we've added a lot of
play progression to the game so you can
get your weapons and you can upgrade
them in various different ways being in
the sort of alternate world war to
reality we've gone further more
over-the-top great electric attachments
there which will charge up over time and
then make your bullets electrical which
will let's break it down for someone who
was completely new to this here he's
like what is the basic premise so the
basic premise is you need to survive
your way through hordes plays wonderful
player cooperative as well so you can
play it on your own like Vicki is doing
just now or you can play up to four
players so we have confirmed four player
co-op grab of action
awesome PvE PvE based specifically only
or PV
absolutely fantastic what engine is he
running if you know this is our own
engine this is a zero so we've been
building upon on this for the last 20
years or so now this is different I
believe you guys also had the title
strange but grade now is this a similar
engine to the arrow this is completely
same same engine same engine used at our
remember she looked absolutely awesome I
did so I covered that last year I look
absolutely fantastic so it's good to see
so and over the shoulder action game
world looks really really good right now
and we're just getting into the action
of zombie so just exploring picking up
some items these are supply crates they
randomized what they might contain so
sometimes they'll have grenades
sometimes might have traps and depending
what you get hold of vary the way you
can deal with like some of the type of
items that would you would kind of
receive in these kind of crates like it
so you could get just your normal frag
grenade but you might get something like
Vicki just picked up there I think a
couple of electric grenades okay they
will act quite different to normal one
stead of just obliterating everything
its path they will shock the enemies in
initial explosion which will burst the
heads but then other nearby zombies will
get shot and fall to the floor area of
effect exactly and it gives you a bit of
extra time as well because well they're
stunned on the floor off see they're not
getting closer to you right if you
really want to make the most of it it's
good to run forward it risky but then
you can stop we like the starboard or
apart this is would you say this is very
early in the game at the very beginning
of the game part of our first level
we've skipped over the very early bit
loops or in the cutscenes let's say this
is still after their very first must say
the engine looks absolutely fantastic so
what would you say are we targeting at
30 fps or books are being running
30 FPS cinematics going on right now a
train going in zombies attacking the
Train what I like off the top is very
like the boombastic over-the-top nature
but it looks very action-oriented very
intense and I'm assuming we're gonna see
a whole bunch of swords and swarms wow
we got some great sniper kills going on
right now and I did see in there there
was like almost like a weapon talent
system like a upgrade system now is dad
per each weapon like every weapon yet
each weapon can be upgraded and each
weapon class as well has also got a
weapon assist so if you get enough kills
with the save the rifle that you're
carrying okay you'll be able to use this
weapon assist which will turn the rifle
into it shot into something it's
extremely powerful it'll just blast
through all the enemies just bursting
them out right and it's great for use
even for sort of crowd control when
you've got a lot of them in a row first
three loads of them the others will fall
back in the weapon or yet for the
weapons you find weapon upgrade kits as
well around and then you can use them
for any anyone I find so nice you can
choose how you want to upgrade now when
I notice when a zombies get up course
out of question for you any type of I
can electric function is on very very
exact and we've got a few other special
melee attacks as well they're all very
exciting and they can be upgraded to so
as well that's not charged up you're
just bashing with the gun which can
knock them down give me a chance to do
that stomp again gotcha gotcha so you
still have basic meal like we just saw
just then
and stop finishes okay almost like a
Gears of War pubstomp going on
once you get a 10-q combo you'll be
rewarded with a takedown and then you
can get up placed one zombies also gives
you some health back so it's like you
want to get up close yes
so again so basic again if you get up
close we can put the barrel of gun in
the zombies mouth blow it off and get
some health back
I like that trade-off play I could
totally imagine bunch of you playing
this with friends having a good time
what would you guys feel like you
learned as far as level design and
actually how much like levels are in the
game if you know of top so but we do
have some areas in them open up a bit
more and give you a bit more directions
you're going there is some choice in in
the path you take as far as the openness
of the lower yet they'll just open up
this not like major choice you might go
right left right see completely
different things but it's just open up a
bit more and depending on the type of
enemies you happen to deal with because
we've got a of enemies some of them you
need a bit more space to move around in
this and it's great when you're in full
echo what platforms are we looking for
zombie army for we've got Xbox one
Playstation 4 and PC super excited game
looks absolutely fantastic zombie army 4
has my attention rebellion with another
over-the-top humor and fun cannot wait
my super excited man super excited carry
let you did fine we enjoy the up-close
combos
[Laughter]
Lopez loads of gaming down that zombie
army for artists England's absolutely
fantastic I cannot wait it's on my list
for e3 thank you guys
[Applause]
[Music]
you see this a workbench you can use it
to switch your old weapons for nice
shiny new ones
don't be shy try it out
[Music]
another earthquake becoming more
frequent that's the cost today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
stay down
yes I'm on a roll
honey daddy's room it takes a long way
around
[Applause]
hi be sport
this is
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
shoot six posies
[Applause]
it's a suicide